hello I'm Nicholas Hall and I'm here to
read first tweets with BuzzFeed
hopefully there are some of them that
exist I've been told there are actually
it was all just me writing these last
night
I'm sorry but I could watch Nicholas
hope sharpen a pencil and it would turn
me on I yeah I mean sharpening a pencil
it's not unirotic I get that and the
name isn't blood I could
okay
okay that's between us don't worry we'll
definitely be watching Renfield because
one horny for vampires aren't we all I
get that two eternally delighted by
movies in which Nicholas Hull plays a
weird fellow thank you yeah I do like
playing weird fellas that was sweet that
was nice the horn there was just for
vampires in general so I can appreciate
that okay but Nicholas Holt was hot as
Tony and skins in 2008 how is it
possible he's gotten hotter every year
oh thank you that's very kind of you
that's quite a while ago now 2008. was
that 15 years no 16 a long time anyway
appreciate it I don't even know this
Nicholas Holt's thighs in the great
trailer
I shouldn't be the same are my thighs in
that trailer I don't remember my thighs
I don't remember the trailer come to
think of it but thanks I suppose I'm
gonna go back and watch it were they my
thighs
number five the favorite made me realize
that my king is Nicholas Holt in a
powdered wig pushing me in a ditch
push me in a ditch neck thank you that
actually funny story about that moment
with Emma when I went to push her in the
ditch I obviously the comedy in that
scene is how violent my character can be
towards her character and pushing her in
the ditch and so we lined up for the
rehearsal and I did just like really
give her a good shot when she went
flying down the hill and I had to
apologize and it was a bit too much so
I'm sorry again for that Nicholas Holt
is the most attractive a man can be in
my opinion as a lesbian all right
that's a win that's a win that's what
we're here for just how many
times did Nicholas Holt smirk on skins I
just oh God I'm pregnant I don't know if
those are two related things did they
just find out they were pregnant whilst
writing that tweet who knows but I did
smirk a lot in that I think I saw the
advert for it I remember being like and
it was like a one-sided murky grin I
don't know why I was doing that so much
as that character I didn't like it but I
guess if you did thank you
my mom is trying to stop me from
fangirling over how hot Nicholas Holt
looks got off
I guess
to your mum don't say that to your mum
that's not nice let's get your mum on
board come on join in mum number nine
let's clean the searches Nicholas helps
sexy Nicholas Hulk villain Nicholas hot
there's hot sexy antagonist oh you're
getting thoughtful with the searches
there fine it'll just hold shoot me I
think let's hope step me oh it gets it
gets pretty dark there doesn't it
towards the end sexy antagonist is
probably my favorite of those searches
those are probably all you to try and
find these uh these thirst tweets right
let's hope it's fine cannot stress this
enough just spread him on a cracker and
that's fine if that's as bad as it gets
I'm okay I got thick skin here we go
Nicholas hope makes me feel feral at any
time but hairy chest
Daddy
[Laughter]
I shaved my chest hair once into an X
when we were filming X-Men I don't know
why number 12 Nicholas Holt showing ass
in the great one of the things that got
me through 2020. all right we all have
to have something to get us through I'm
glad I could be yours I had to get my
ass out for a long time there was one
scene the the corridor I had to walk
down was about 300 yards long but naked
and when Tony the creator of the show
asked me about doing that scene
he was like oh and there's going to be
about 70 extras in the hallway and I was
like 70 people butt naked I don't know
if I want to do that Tony so we
negotiated and we got it down to about
30 people which was much more
comfortable for me thank you Tony we've
got a train Enthusiast here because they
say I want Nicholas Holt to rail me in a
way no human has ever been railed before
I'm serious choo choo
it does get a bit worse why are people
putting this stuff out uh the way I want
Nicholas Hull to sit on my face until
I'm dead
I can't tell what emoji that is it's
like a little red face oh it's sweating
enough said
I would totally
look Nicholas Holt's to test if
it was delicious for no other reason for
no other reason just to make sure
there's no other purpose for that surely
oh it's getting it's getting Acy the
cheeseburger in the menu actually
symbolizes how much I want to eat
Nicholas Holt's ass which is true when
the script was written that was kind of
the uh the metaphor and the symbolism
that they were reaching for with that
story so I'm glad you picked up on it
astute astute viewing I'm gonna get
Nicholas Holt's face tattooed on my
right ass cheek so I can say I sit on
Nick's face all the time
classic spit in my mouth and I would use
it as mouthwash okay I'd let Nicholas
Hulk go balls deep I ain't afraid of
that
I made it through I got to the end ain't
shocked by none of that I wrote them all
and I'll do it again
I feel objectified in the most wonderful
way I've remembered all the handles of
the people that wrote those beautiful
tweets about me thank you I will be
sliding into your DMs later this evening
um I appreciate all the all the thirst
love if you have a spare moment perhaps
you could spare some time to go watch
Renfield in theaters you might like it I
don't get naked though or do I
actually
[Music]